hello everyone and welcome to the only
game ever played between Michael tall
and Viswanathan Anand the game was
played in 1989 in con France and other
than this I couldn't find any more
information about this tournament if it
even was a tournament maybe some of you
have will have some better luck finding
any information on it maybe someone who
is from France but I really couldn't if
you're able please do share in the
comments I will add it in the
description so people people can check
it out and this was a this was played
some three years before before talus
death and Anand was since I don't know
the exact date at this time but this
game was played that he was around 19 or
or maybe 20 so let's see this game it's
a quite an interesting game tall has the
white pieces and he plays c4 he tall
goes for the English opening c5 the
symmetrical variation Knight to f3 and
Knight to c6 Knight to c3 now the two
knights variation of the English and
here Aran goes for already a peculiar
move right from the opening he plays
Knight to d4 top plays
III of course he is not interested in
wasting the temple by capturing Knight
characters on f3 and Queen captures only
three we have g6 by Anand b3 and Bishop
to g7 island is locking down to this d4
square on a disabling toll from playing
d4 Thal goes Bishop to the to d6 now g3
and rook to b8 this is a good move by
Anand as it moves the rook from this
long diagonal the queen is eyeing eight
the bishop will also be I Inc a eight so
it's a good idea to move the rock before
it before you know how it gets a chance
to attack it and also it's protecting
the b7 pawn so this Bishop is free to be
developed
we have Bishop g2 by tile and night to
h6 and this is definitely a good move as
developing the night for example to f6
allows ideas like like Knight to d5 now
this this becomes a very strong Bishop
and other than other than this maybe
even d4 immediately as possible for tall
so definitely developing the knight to
h6 is a good idea here we have Queen to
d1 if tall castles here prematurely then
Bishop to g4 might be might be annoying
for him
so after night h6 acquainted the one was
played and we have castles by Anand tal
castles and Bishop to d7 now as you can
see this rogue comes very handy in
defending the b7 pawn a4 by tell not
allowing current to push b5 Bishop to c6
countering that beautiful light square
bishop on G to d4 we have Bishop
captures King captures and rook the c8
and here it's not really a critical
position but it's so it's one that
really gives black a bit too much
Oh Tull here played Queen to d3 but what
he should have gone for is D captures on
c5 and after rook captures on c5 Queen
c2 this would be perfectly fine you'll
see why instead Tull played Queen to d3
and now on and immediately captures C
capture Sun before he captures on d4 and
Knight to f5 wentao allowed this e3 pawn
to capture on thief on d4 there is no
more efore move to kick the night away
from f5 and this is a beautiful square
for the knight you can't really hope to
kick it away with the g4 then the knight
h4 check you'll have to take that into
account and definitely a better idea
would have been foretell to capture D
captures on c5 and Aleta leave his pawn
on e3 so so tower would be able to kick
the night away from f5 d 5 now I'll grab
some space in the center Queen to b6
that's a definitely the best where for
Anand to develop his Queen and now the
rooks are connected also this comes over
the tempo of detecting the b3 pawn and
we have night 2 d1 now the queen is
protecting the b3 pawn bishop capture
some b2 Knight captures some
- and E 5 now D captures on e6 and
probably probably the best move wasn't
to capture this on Poisson as probably
blocking it maybe Riemann over in the
night with 91-93 but ok top lady
captures an e6 and the hill out on and
open up the DF file also now Anand has a
pretty strong center here and tell
probably did did this to make this d6
pawn a weakness later on so rook a to
the 1 by tau rook to f6 now and rook to
D 2 by tau and you might think that this
is a pretty good idea I mean the Queen
and the rook are attacking the d6 pawn
this Queen and this Knight are defending
it so why not play g4 and kick away the
defender of the d6 pawn the problem is
this loses tactically if g4 then Knight
captures on H night night to h4 check
King do you want a now Queen to c6
threatening checkmate on g2 and it's not
very easy to stop this after you play
something like Queen to g3 you get
Knight to f3 check the King has to move
king h1 and all nights the d2 check and
however you block this check for example
f3 Knight captures rook on f1 I don't
deserve the exchange and winning the
game so after rook f6 top plate
rook to d2 also this has protection to
DF 2 pawn as this rook and queen are
eyeing that
f2 pawn we have E 5 now Queen to d5
check by towel kingi 7 and queen to b5
and table is going to be 5 with the idea
that if Anand captures the Queen this
would this would favour thought this
would be an okay position for white but
this was actually not the best move as
the queen is currently at this beautiful
d5 square the queen is perfectly
centralized and you don't want to move
your queen wave if you're not gaining
anything better was for example Knights
to d3 and then Ramona ring the night to
it to a more active square so okay now
they play Queen to b5 and of
Anand doesn't wanna trade queens he
plays Queen to c7 and here Tull should
have should have admitted the mistake
that Queen to b5 wasn't the best move
and he should have retreated with the
Queen to d5 and if queen defy was played
here it's a it's a perfectly good
position for white and for black this is
probably probably I mean I'm not saying
it would be a draw but you know both
sides can play but Tom played c5 now and
of course you can't capture D captures
and c5 Rock c7 Rudy 7 is checked for
King the king and the Queen and Aaron
loses the Queen but another display
Queen captures on c5 now
Anand offers the exchange of Queens but
da offers captures Queen Katharine b7
this is with check rook to c7 blocking
and now tau plays Queen to d5 now again
tile offers the exchange of Queens and
this is what the idea tells so that he
couldn't really do anything you know he
didn't really want to draw by repeating
that Queen b-52 Queen d5 as well if he
doesn't want to get he doesn't want to
let young on the get away with a draw
and if I don't the straight Queens here
Queen Catherine's on d5 tall had in mind
rook captures and after something like
roof to c3 a knight Knight to c4
attacking the d6 pawn and after real
Katra struck to d1 rugby for attacking
the a for pawn and after Knight captures
knife captures rook captures rook
captures and rook captures Anand would
capture this pawn and after roof to d7
something like King h6 you do have to
keep defending the h7 pawn and h4 Anand
would be upon up but with three pawn
with three point islands it would be
very hard to convert this into a win but
after Queen to d5 now and isn't
interested in a draw now on at place
Queen to b4 and now towel will get into
some serious trouble
rook F 2 d1 adding further protection to
this rook and e2 and also adding more
pressure to the d6
pawn rook the rook the c5 now with a
temple on the Queen and we have Queen to
a8 now tower wants to get back his pawn
and Queen captures unbe three and Tao
plays Knight to d3 here
unfortunately capturing the pawn doesn't
work even if it comes with check if
Queen captures an a7 would check rook to
f7 blocking would attempt on the Queen
Queen a6 and now Knight to d4
threatening some Queen to have three
ideas Queen to d5 ideas this is all with
check and after something like Queen to
d3 not mean to d5 check King g1 and
Knight to f3 check the King has to go to
f1 if the King goes to h1 then of course
this Queen to a8 move is is destructive
of course salmon doesn't trade Queens he
still keeps an eye on this King and now
wherever the knight moves white is
doomed
for example Queen to f1 if you don't
move the Queen something like night
Stewie one will win the Queen so after
Queen to f1 now Knight will capture the
Rockwood check however you block for
example Queen to G 294 and Anand is up a
whole rook so in this position after
Knight to f3 check you do have to play
King to f1 but now Knight captures on h2
you don't even have to rush with
grabbing the rook king jumong now Knight
f3 check King f1 and now you simply
capture the rook and after rook captures
simply Queen to h1 check King e2 and
after something like d5 you're down the
exchange and you're getting crushed
these bones are very scary
so after Queen to b3 towel doesn't
capture the pawn with check rather he
brings the the night into the defense
night to d3 with a temple on the rook we
have rook to c2 now by Anand and Queen
to e4 by tau
again capturing on a7 doesn't work even
in this position with check rook f7 pin
a6 and now again Queen to d5 check King
moves
rook captures rook captures and Queen to
e4 and it's it's very hard for example H
three nights to d4 again this night will
come to f3 and everything will be the
same a very bad position for tall
so after up to see to Queen to e4 now
Tao brings the Queen back into the
defense rook to see for attacking the
Queen Queen to d5 pinning the rook but
Queen to c3 unpinning and we have worked
to be 2 by tau good ideas of ruby 7
check ok the Queen is guarding f7 but
Anand always has this escape route which
came to h6 rook to d4 now with the tempo
on the Queen and also with a double
attack on the knight now rook to b7
check by tau King h6 and out Queen to b5
the Queen has to protect the night as
its attacked twice but now white is
simply white simply can't defend every
threat and Anand finds the best move he
plays Knight to e3 check what do you do
here now plays King to g1 if you capture
the night with F characters on e3 Queen
to c2 check and it's pretty much over
the rook is slicing all the way here if
you go to g1 or h1 with the King Queen
captures rook you're getting checkmated
and you can't even run away with King to
h3 rock to h4 check now finishes the
game and it doesn't matter if King to h4
Queen captures on h2 kingi for queen h5
is checkmate and if you capture with the
pawn doesn't really matter
rook to f3 check King g4 Queen to g2 is
checkmate
so after 933 with check top life King to
g1 Queen to c2 now again threatening bf
to pawn still the night is attacked
twice
threatening to capture the rook but this
Queen the c2 wasn't really necessary a
winning move is just as well the simple
Knight captures rook or even rook
captures on f2 but Anand isn't in a
hurry this position is simply too good
for black Queen to c2
we have rook to f1 by towel and now on
simply place
on the three honored wins apiece and in
this position Michael Tao resigned the
game there's really no move he can play
he can't capture the night only three F
captures only three results in the very
quick rook captures and f1 will check
only movie screen captures f1 and now
rook to d1 is checkmate so yeah a very
nice game and you know the only this is
the only encounter between former world
champions Michael Tao and Vishwanathan
Anand so definitely definitely very nice
cross-generational game and and uh you
know a gem in the history of chess so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it like I said I couldn't find
any more information why this game was
played was the tournament or what I know
that in in Khan they are organizing a
chess festival every year so maybe it
was a part of that maybe maybe some of
you know especially someone from France
might know so yeah that's it
I would like to thank Christos gnosis
hans-juergen Nielson and an unknown
person for your contribution to my
channel thank a lot - really appreciate
it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon